este problema es exacto para practicar
desigualdades y sistemas de
desigualdades este problema me parece
buenísimo realmente nos vamos a divertir
con él el problema dice louis recibir
una tarjeta de regalo por valor de 25
pesos de una tienda en línea dedicada a
la venta de música digital y de juegos
cada canción cuesta un peso y cada juego
cuesta dos pesos si además él quiere
comprar al menos 15 artículos con su
tarjeta de regalo escribe un sistema de
desigualdades que representen el
problema e identifica el rango de
posibles compras usando una gráfica
bueno lo primero que va a hacer es
definir variables es que voy a decir que
sea m igual al número de canciones que
puede
louis comprar y bueno m por música y
después voy a tomarme a gm como mi otra
variable y voy a decir que gm va a ser
igual a de espera espera espera de hecho
me gustaría más pensar en dos variables
completamente aleatorias así que voy a
tomar menos en lo que se me ocurra s voy
a decir que es el número de canciones
que puede comprar
y voy a decir que es igual al número de
juegos que él puede comprar y lo primero
que quiero que veas es que yo sé que la
suma de s
+ g es decir del número de canciones más
el número de juegos tiene que ser al
menos 15 esto es lo que nos dice el
problema él quiere comprar al menos 15
artículos con su tarjeta de regalo por
lo tanto es más que tiene que ser mayor
o igual que 15 el número de canciones
más el número de juegos tiene que ser
mayor o igual que los 15 artículos que
al menos luis quiere comprar puede ser
igual de 15 porque podemos comprar
solamente 15 artículos pero también
puede ser mayor o igual que piensa es
decir puede ser 16 17 18 19 lo que sea y
por otra parte el problema nos dice que
louis puede gastar hasta 25 pesos que
era lo que tenía la tarjeta de regalo y
que cada canción cuesta un peso y que
cada juego cuesta dos pesos como podemos
escribir una desigualdad con esto bueno
vamos a escribir primero lo que está
gastando louis lo que gasta louis es la
cantidad de canciones que él va a
comprar por uno porque un peso al de
cada una de estas canciones más
dos veces la cantidad de juegos que va a
comprar y este 2 sale porque cada uno de
los juegos vale 2 pesos así que si por
ejemplo nosotros tenemos que louis
compras cinco juegos y cuatro canciones
entonces tendríamos 2 por 5 10 + 4 son
14 pesos el gastaría 14 pesos y bueno
estoy remitiendo el uno al lado de la s
porque recuerda que multiplicar por 1 es
dejar las cosas tal cual aunque cada
canción vale un peso y bueno lo que
gasta tiene que ser menor o igual que 25
pesos el pueda gastar 25 pesos pero no
se puede pasar de 25 pesos porque es lo
que tiene en su tarjeta de regalo y ya
que tenemos este sistema de
desigualdades
ahora vamos a graficar este sistema de
desigualdades así que para esto déjame
aquí graficar dos ejes y ahorita vamos a
tomar la decisión de que está en cada
uno de los ejes y por cierto solamente
voy a graficar el primer cuadrante es
decir donde ese eje son positivos este
base del eje de las ss
este es va a ser el eje de las que es
porque solamente tienen sentido comprar
un número de juegos y de canciones
positivos y bueno para graficar este
desigualdades lo primero que me tengo
que fijar es en las líneas límite o
dicho de otra manera en los bordes y
para esto lo que puedes escribir estas
desigualdades en su forma pendiente
orden al origen y para esto voy a
despejar a mi variable s de la primera
tengo que s es mayor o igual que menos
que más 15 menos que más 15 y bueno de
la segunda tengo y mejor déjame ponerlo
con color magenta de la segunda voy a
tener si despejó a ese que éste va a ser
menor o igual que menos 2 g más 25 ese
va a ser menor o igual que menos dos que
más 25 y bueno esto lo estoy haciendo
porque yo puedo asociar una ecuación de
la recta a cada una de estas
desigualdades para encontrar mi borde mi
frontera de esta desigualdad así que
empecemos con la primera si de ésta yo
tomo una ecuación de la recta asociada a
esta misma desigualdad que me voy a
encontrar bueno que éste va a ser igual
a menos gm más 15 éste va a ser igual a
menos g más 15 y qué pasa con esta recta
si te das cuenta corta al eje de las
heces en el valor de 15 entonces
tenemos el 5 y el 10 el 15 y por aquí
pasan mi recta y después si yo quisiera
hacer ese igual a 0 entonces obtendría
que menos que más 15 es igual a 0 y si t
aquí despejó a g no quedaría kg es igual
a 15 que es igual a 15 y por lo tanto
corta elegirlas que es también en el
valor de 15 así que vamos a ponerlo por
acá aquí voy a tener el valor de 5 por
aquí por aquí me voy a tomar el valor de
10 aquí el de 15 y por aquí también pasa
mi recta y ahora si uno de los dos
puntos y como tengo un mayor igual puedo
dibujar una recta sólida es decir en
lugar de una recta punteada voy a
dibujar una recta sólida porque todo
esto también es parte de mi solución y
si te das cuenta lo que tengo es ese más
que mayor o igual que piense en la
desigualdad original por lo tanto me voy
a fijar en todo lo que está arriba de
esta recta todo lo que está arriba de
esta recta cumple esta desigualdad
cualquier punto cuyas coordenadas sean
de la forma que coma ese que cumpla esta
desigualdad tiene que tocar o esta línea
recta o tiene que estar arriba de estas
rectas de mi frontera
tanto déjenme colorearlo también de
verde todo lo que esté arriba de esta
recta va a cumplir esta desigualdad y tú
lo puedes verificar por ejemplo si
tomamos el 0 0 el 0 0 pues eso no va a
ser mayor o igual que 15 por lo tanto no
lo cumplen no está en esta parte y si
tomamos un punto aquí por ejemplo el
15,15 15 + 15 30 lo cual es mayor o
igual que 15 por lo tanto si cumplen
esta desigualdad y si te das cuenta son
todos estos puntos aquí ahora vamos a
fijarnos qué es lo que tenemos con
nuestra segunda desigualdad si nosotros
buscamos el límite o la frontera
tendríamos que s es igual a menos dos
que más 25 y de igual manera sigue vale
0 entonces el cev al de 25 así que aquí
vamos a tener 20 aquí el 25 y por aquí
justo por aquí pasa mi recta ahora por
otra parte si ese vale cero entonces me
va a quedar que cero es igual a menos
dos que más 25 y si yo paso es del otro
lado sumando me queda que 2 que es igual
a 25 y de aquí dividiendo entre 2 me
queda que gm es igual a 25 entre 2 lo
cual es 12.5 12.5 o dos enteros un medio
y eso está como por aquí
cortamos al eje
justo aquí aquí tenemos al 12.5 bueno
creo que no de hecho creo que es justo
la mitad esta sería mi mitad y justo por
aquí pasa mi frontera y si te das cuenta
en frontera también es salida porque
tenemos un menor o igual por lo tanto
vamos a dibujar a que me frontera ya
tengo mi frontera o mil bordes de todo
el conjunto solución de esta desigualdad
y ahora tanto cuenta que tenemos en esta
desigualdad ese menor o igual que menos
dos gemas 25 en la desigualdad de
original teníamos que s más 2 que es
menor o igual que 25 por lo tanto todos
los que están aquí abajo todos los que
están abajo de esta frontera son parte
de mi solución y de igual manera tú lo
puedes verificar si tomamos por ejemplo
un punto adentro de un punto fuera vamos
a ver qué es lo que sucede el 0 0 esto
claro que se cumple porque 0 es menor o
igual que 25 y si tomamos ahora el 15,15
15 más 2 por 15 es último que tres veces
15 lo cual es 45 y 45 no es menor o
igual que 25 por lo tanto estamos bien
ahora
el conjunto solución que cumple
simultáneamente ambas desigualdades es
donde se traslapan estos dos colores es
decir donde tenemos en esta gráfica de
aquí una combinación de los dos colores
del verde y del agente y si te das
cuenta es justo esta parte de aquí esta
parte de aquí es donde se traslapan
estos dos colores y no solamente esta
parte también las fronteras porque en
ambas desigualdades son desigualdades
amplias por lo tanto también tocamos
estos bordes de aquí y más aún ya
podemos construir en este problema que
cualquier combinación de canciones y de
juegos que tomemos en esta región de
aquí va a cumplir ambas desigualdades
simultáneamente